une surprise pour cette 100e édition de
l'open de france tong chaï jeddi 46 ans
remporte le tournoi avec une carte de 68
soit 11 coups sous le par
le sportif devance l'italien francesco
molinari de quatre coups le golfeur
devient par la même occasion le premier
asiatique à remporter cette compétition
depuis 1971 armes spéciales week for me
et north wind
je pense que ce week end était vraiment
spécial et c'était un grand week-end
pour moi c'est la plus grande victoire
de ma vie et remporter cette coupe était
vraiment fantastique
croyez moi je suis vraiment ravi de sa
c'est absolument parfait parti à deux
coups de la tête la superstar de cet
open de france rory mcilroy n'a pas pu
bousculer le thaïlandais dans la
dernière journée le 4e mondial signe une
carte de 71 pour terminer troisièmes à
cinq coups du leader
ça a été difficile de mettre vos prix du
beurre 10 les conditions n'étaient pas
excellentes pour le faire
tong chaï a joué de façon très
impressionnante et je pense que je
n'avais aucune chance de gagner les
derniers coups n'étaient pas trop mal je
pense que je suis dans la bonne
direction
du côté des français julien quesne et
mathieu decottignies lafon terminé 16e
ex-aequo et grégory bourdy a lui fini
25e le chouchou du public français
victor dubuisson terminant 66e et
dernière position de l'open de france
avec une carte de plus 17
son plus mauvais score en huit éditions
au golf national